[Music]
and today's question
comes from matthew in tennessee my
fiance and i will be getting married in
november we're both 20 years old
i make 60 000 as a welder she makes 12
000 as a preschool teacher and is in
college
i have no debts and also 401k she has
about five thousand dollars in student
loans
and a car loan we have an apartment
together and a joint bank account that i
put money in
for her to handle my bills while i'm out
of town for work
how does the whole process what does the
whole process look like when combining
finances
after getting married um
well matthew sound like you're kind of
already doing it a little bit so
between now and november i know it
sounds like a hassle but honestly i
would still practice
separating those finances until you guys
officially are married in november
stuff happens and you never know
so i would still keep things separate i
would not pay on her debt right now
i would be paying my own bills again
keeping it separate until you guys
get married say i do and then the moment
you guys do that
then what you're doing now which a
little bit of practice which is good is
the joint checking account so having one
account that you guys are working out of
this is a big hurdle for a lot of
couples it's tough for them to combine
accounts for many different reasons but
that's a tactical step for you guys to
do and then
see this debt that she's bringing in
which is
some student loans in a car loan as your
debt that it's it's our debt together
once we're married
and for you guys to pause that 401k
that you have and take all the extra
money you guys have and and pay off this
debt and get an emergency fund so that's
kind of the
the way to look at it get the plan um
but there
is there is such a push for me when you
get married and only when
that you say okay we have one budget we
have one account we're working out of
and that
unity is created kind of almost this
forced communication in a sense
um after after the after the wedding
yeah
after the wedding when you do one
checking account um
that forces you to to talk about
money and to have a planned budget
because if you don't you're gonna
overdrive the account because she's
writing checks you're writing checks
you're she's using debit card using
debit card
and we don't know we don't know what the
balance is so the only way you can run
an account together
is it forces you to communicate about it
it forces you to have a budget and to
stick to it
uh because if you don't you're gonna
screw up your checking account you're
going to overdraft
and you're going to be mad at each other
because you can't just run off and do
your own thing anymore
cause you're married this is how
marriage works you do it together
and here's the beautiful part about the
whole thing when
when you combine
your spending and you agree on your
spending
jesus said your treasure is where your
heart is when you're in agreement
about what our future looks like and
that we are moving in the same direction
you create a level of unity in your
marriage a level of communication you
cannot do with any other subject
money forces you to combine your value
system
you have to say we value saving we
value generosity we value
investing uh we value
spending on money on x or y
as a couple and or
she values this and i love her and so
this is something that we put the
category in
for her but and i value her having that
thing
yeah whatever it is art class or what i
don't care what it is okay
but it's not just you know
the mistake that people are making in
our culture today
and it's going to be so detrimental 10
years into your marriage
20 years in your marriage it's going to
be a problem is you
think that you can live this life of
independence
with your roommate and that is not
marriage
and you're going to get into a problem
and you guys are probably going to talk
about that
marriage yes because it's so interesting
out of all i'm
independent then don't get married no
out of all the things
that i talk about specifically on social
media the one thing that people get
so angry at me i mean the con it's the
most hateful comments that i get
is when i say join your bank accounts i
mean you would think
that i like ran over someone's dog and
like laughed in their faces i mean like
you would think i'm the most horrible
person in the world and so
what i'm finding is the more and more i
dig into the subject which again john
and i are unpacking so much of this
because it's not just that it's not i
just won't join my checking account
there's a level of control people have
there's a level of trust that they don't
have with there's i mean there's so many
of those issues you guys that is unjust
really they they're they don't want to
deal with their crap
and they get mad at the avoidance and
they and but they call it like
feminism or something like that oh no
well you don't want women to have a
voice no we demand
they have a voice in the budget with
their husband right right
we demand the husband has a voice in
there with his wife and so
it's telling you too it's in money
fights and
and conflict when it's avoided
sure you're not having it because you're
not talking about it you're living two
separate lives financially
and if and people say well we just fight
all the time so like it's just worth not
like if you're choosing to avoid what's
going on in this situation
what other things are not you're not
you're not pressing into conflict at all
right
let me help you with this in marriage
avoidance is not
a technique
[Laughter]
less spirit that says buried buried
problems have a high rate of
resurrection
they're coming up yeah but it just but
it again it's it's this mirror of like
all this other stuff so it's just funny
i'm like you will share a child like you
will create a human being
and share a child and share decision
making about it
i know but it is strong out there for
people so
it's big it's big so it's fun well it's
misguided
toxic version of ladies having their
voice
yes ladies ladies need to have their
voice yeah yeah there's
there's that side that's what they're
attacking but there's also there's also
another side where he's like i don't
want to deal
don't [ __ ] at me about that they [ __ ]
you cause you're a woman maybe that's
what it is i don't know but
it's that side but it's also the guy's
side too saying stuff like i don't want
to deal with it
we're so much better if we're just
separate oh i know that but i'm like
dude
they're not they're not they're not
hating on you though
everyone everyone hates it
i love it i like to be liked i love it